so rodney i want to go a little big
picture with this we know how tough
devontae adams is but green bay played
jacksonville why do you have them in
your top five at this point
well you asked me why i have them um
because they haven't been they haven't
been great on defense and they were
missing their two starting corners
yesterday and zadaria smith the last
couple games he had he's had a couple
sacks a force fumble preston smith
hasn't put up a lot of great stats but
he forced um some pressure last week
forced an interception had a sack so i
look at their defense and even um adrian
amos he had an interception but i look
at their defense and really has been an
inconsistent part of of their team
stopping the run and just you know
continue to make big plays and but to
play without your two-star corner
starting cornerbacks and still be able
to pull that game off and you think
about jacksonville you got to give them
a lot of credit they played hard they
played tough they made some plays and
they weren't afraid they weren't afraid
of aaron rodgers they picked them off
and they were talking some trash so you
know here look here in the next three or
four years watch out for the
jacksonville jaguars because they're at
least right now they are at least
competitive
what was a little bit weird about
watching this game for the packers
offensively it seemed like aaron jones
got a demotion in the first half he just
wasn't getting any touches really
throughout the game only 13 is what he
finished with they weren't getting him
involved in the passing game like we're
used to seeing so it was a lot of
devante adams there's a lot of marquez
valdez scantling but aaron jones wasn't
that third piece that third weapon that
aaron rodgers likes likes to use so much
and since they weren't using him like
that
it just seemed like the offense was off
to a slow start they mixed them in more
and more in the second but it was the
power running game they were trying to
get going in the first which is a debate
that we've had on this show it wasn't
working they spread it out in the second
half and they ultimately go win the game
by four
what's the kid's name i forget his name
irving number 32 right what's this i
forget his name i'm i'm sorry um but
they're they're incorpora yeah they're
incorporating him more because what
they're trying to do is they know how
how special aaron jones is and and
basically what he is and no disrespect
behind this but he's like a poor man's
aaron jones so if you can give him more
reps aaron jones just came off this
injury where he missed a bunch of time
and you don't want to put reinstall him
in the offense and give him 20 25 plays
and overuse him and get him back hurt so
what they're doing is they're saying you
know what we're doing well we're playing
against the jacksonville jaguars i don't
care if we're playing against the san
francisco 49ers we'll give him 10 to 15
touches we'll get his conditioning back
we'll make sure that he's healthy and
that he's safe so we can have them
toward the latter part of the season
which i think is smart but you're also
getting some other young guys that
experience and you know if aaron jones
get hurt then they have more depth they
can they can do other things with other
people and i think that's important
yeah yeah i'm right there with you tyler
irvin uh you know marquez
scantling
no no no he got it right so so marquez
valdez scantling you're always wondering
is he really a good enough number two
wide receiver aaron rodgers and we've
debated that out on this show they chose
not to draft you know use a high draft
pick to go get another wide receiver for
aaron rodgers instead they go
back up quarterback of the future power
running back rounds one and two of the
draft and you do see a little bit of
them trying to transition this running
attack to that always seems more
successful when it's jones do you think
marquez valdez scantling is a talented
enough number two assuming that they
figure out a way which sounds like
devante adams is banged up assuming they
do have atoms for the course of this
year is him and valdez scantling enough
because there's not really a tight end
you think about there's not really a
third wide receiver that scares you it
just seems like it's an offense we
talked about the bucks we talked about
the steelers we talked about kansas city
they're not even close to the amount of
playmakers that those top teams have
well i look at the packers and and
robert tunyan who's a tight end who's
caught a lot of touchdowns from aaron
rodgers a guy that aaron rodgers really
trust and believe in so i would say yes
because you know as a number two
receiver for the green bay packers you
don't have to be great i think um mvs i
think he's fast he puts a lot of
pressure on the defense and every time i
look up
he's behind the safety he's behind the
corner so yeah i mean he's stretching
the field robert tunyan you get all
these other guys tyler irvin you get
aaron jones i mean
you know occupying the middle of the
field and why do you think devonta adams
is so wide open all the time and i don't
understand this because i called out my
old defensive coordinator
romeo cornell for not double teaming him
with the houston texans and then i come
back and watch the san francisco 49ers
not double cover him he is one he's an
elite receiver you have to double cover
him and they do such a great job of
quick passes to him because he's a
bigger receiver six two six three he can
run people over and look how big and
thick he is as a wide receiver and he
has a running backs mentality so they
try to get him the ball as much as
possible and any time aaron rodgers
comes up to the line of scrimmage and he
sees two safeties back it's a handoff
when you see that safety creeps down
he's throwing the ball and that's that's
what he's doing and that's what you
trust about aaron rodgers he's so smart
he can get you in a perfect play he can
get you in the right play in the right
position and that's why they've been so
successful this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports